[موسيقى]
من تحته
شو اسمك
يلا بدنا الوسائل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بسم الله
مشاهدينا نكمل واياكم هذه التغطيه المؤلمه
لهذه الكارثه الانسانيه التي حلت بكل من
تركيا وسوريا سبعه ايام بلياليها وبردها
وقسوتها مرت وما تزال على السوريين
والاتراك الالم بدا يتضاعف مع تضائل الامل
بانقاذ مزيد من الناجين ان كانت اصواتهم
لا تسمع اصلا خمسه
قتيل او اكثر بقليل هي الحصيله المتجدده
لعدد ضحايا الزلزال على طرفي حدوده لتركيا
الحصه الاكبر الى الان حيث اكثر من
29600 قتيل بينما في سوريا وصل العدد
لخمسه الاف شخص لكن هذا الرقم وللاسف
الشديد سيتضاعف لان من بقي يتضاءلت فرصه
خروجه يتنفس
ساعه انتظار طويله احساسها اشبه بايام
لكنها ختمت اسبوعها الاول بالفعل فالزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا دخل يومه
السابع وكافه الضحايا في ميزان العالقين
باتت الراجحه حاليا متخطيه عتبه الثلاثين
الف قتيل
صبرني فيكم يا ربي سبعه ايام قادمه وتزداد
سوادا مع توقعات بارتفاع اعداد القتلى
لنحو الضعف لكن كيف بدات
زلزال بقوه 7.8 درجه ضرب على بعد 17
كيلومترا قرب غازي عنتاب في الساعه
الرابعه وسبعه عشره دقيقه بالتوقيت المحلي
تلاه زلزال اخر واكثر من 650 هزه ارتداديه
وفق مسؤولين اتراك حل مدمرا في عشر ولايات
تركيه وخمس محافظات سوريه شملت حلب وادلب
عدد القتلى تخطى 7500 شخص في البلدين مع
استمرار معارك البحث عن ناجين واعلن
الرئيس التركي حاله الطوارئ بالولايات
العشر المتضرره لثلاثه اشهر لافتا الى
تضرر حوالي 13 مليونا وخمسمائه الف شخص
واحد عشر الف مبنى
ثالث ايام الكارثه شهد تحذيرا من اغلاق
النافذه الذهبيه للعثور على ناجين مع وصول
عدد القتلى الى اكثر من تسعه الاف وست مئه
قتيل
بعدها بيوم عداد الضحايا دقه عتبه العشرين
الفا مع استمرار عمليه البحث والانقاذ كما
سجل التاسع من فبراير وصول اول قافله
مساعدات الى شمال غرب سوريا عبر معبر باب
الهوى اجمالي عدد القتلى واصل ارتفاعه الى
اكثر من 22,000 بالاضافه 82 الف مصاب
حقائق وقاده اردوغان للاعتراف ببطء
استجابه السلطات التركيه للزلازل الجنوبيه
البلاد
مع دخول الكارثه يومها السادس اعلن مدير
الدفاع المدني السوري وقف عمليات الانقاذ
لتبدا عمليات انتشال الضحايا العالقين تحت
الانقاض اما في تركيا فتواصلت عمليات
البحث مسجله معجزه قليله
[موسيقى]
اكثر من 23 مليون شخص تاثروا بالكارثه موت
واصابات وتشريد جروح توازي بعمقها شقوقا
في مباني شبه صامده وطرقات متقطعه
الله اكبر
هذا ورصده كاميرا العربيه توقف نحو 100
شاحنه محمله بالوقود والمواد الاغاثيه
ارسلت من مناطق الاداره الكرديه ولا تزال
عالقه في معبر ام جلود الفاصل بين مناطق
سيطره قصد ومناطق الفصائل المواليه لتركيا
التي ترفض مرور هذه الشاحنات الى ادلب
وريف حلب
لا تزال مساعدات الاداره الذاتيه والاهالي
لمنكوبي زلزال في مناطق المعارضه ونظام
علقه هنا في المعابر هذه القافله تضم 30
صهريجا محمله بالوقود وهي الماده الاكثر
طلبا في عموم سوريا تجمدت هنا منذ ايام
تقول الاداره الذاتيه انها لا تضع اي شروط
لادخالها سوى سلامه السائقين والقافله
ذهبا وايابا بينما الحكومه المؤقته في
شمال غرب البلاد اشارت في بيان لها انها
تقبل مساعدات الاهالي والمنظمات بما معنى
انها ترفض مساعدات الاداره وقصد ليس ببعيد
من هنا علقت 100 شاحنه في معبر التائهه
تحمل الوقود والمواد الاغاثيه والانسانيه
كمساعدات لمناطق النظام يقول الاكراد ان
دمشق تطالب بحصه 80% منها كشرط لادخالها
وفيما يستمر البقاء في تسييس المساعدات
وعرقلتها تزداد معاناه السوريين الذين
وحدهم الزلزال من معبر ام جلود في مدينه
منبج شمال شرق سوريا جماعه كاش للعربيه
والحدث
وايضا من ام جلود في منبج يبقى معنا مراسل
عربيه جمعه عكاش لمتابعه تطورات هذه
القضيه جمعه يعني منذ ان بدات اول قافله
مساعدات ولم تمر وحتى اليوم هناك اتهامات
متبادله بين القصد والفصائل بتسييس هذه
المساعدات ما الذي حل بها وهل ممكن ان تمر
عبر يعني محادثات معينه
يعني حتى الان لم تفلح كل جهود يعني
الجهود والتواصلات بين الطرفين في الوصول
الى نتيجه وسماح لهذه المساعدات بالعمور
ربما المشهد يتعقد اكثر مما كان عليه خلال
اليومين او ثلاثه ايام الماضيه اللاسمه مع
وجود طرف ثالث وهو تركيا الذي كما نسمع من
الاداره الذاتيه بانها تعرقل دخول هذه
المساعدات وتضغط على المعارضه وايضا على
الحكومه المؤقته شمال غرب البلاد بعدم
السماح في دخول هذه الموارد كي لا تكتسب
قصه صفه رسميه والاداره الذاتيه اي طابع
رسمي تكتسب هذه المعابره ايضا طابع الرسم
لانها يبدو حريصه على ايجاد يعني نوع من
التباعد بين المعارضه وقصد لان التركي
لديها رؤيه خاصه في التعامل مع هذه
المنطقه وتعتقد بانها تستطيع التامين
منطقه امنه وطرد الاكراد والاداره على بعد
جمعه
على ما يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال بمراسل
العربيه جمعه عكاش من ام جلود في منبج اذا
كنا نتحدث معه حول موضوع
ايصال المساعدات التي سيرتها اداره
الاداره الذاتيه الكرديه بشمال سوريا الى
المناطق المنكوبه جمعه يعني ايضا بهذا
الاطار هناك اليوم ذريعه لدى جانب الفصائل
وهي موضوع يعني استخدام الاشارات واعلام
المنطقه الذاتيه مما يعتبر موضوع حساس
بالنسبه للاطراف وبالنسبه لهؤلاء مما فيه
يعني اعتبارات سياسيه حساسه هل هذه
الذريعه سحبت من قبل الاكراد عن هذه يعني
اللافتات الموجوده على هذه الشاحنات
يعني اليوم كان احد الناطقين باسم الاداره
يتحدث في المعبر وقال لنا حتى بوضوح انهم
ليس لديهم اي قيد او شرط لادخال هذه
المساعدات حتى انهم مستعدونها يعني ازاله
اسم الاداره الذاتيه المعلقه في صدر هذه
الشاحنات وليس لهم ايضا اي شرط في توصيلها
الى اي مكان من الامكنه ولا يشترطون
توصيلها الى جنديرس ذات الاغلبيه الكرديه
او عفرين
ذات الاغلبيه الكرديه وبالتالي يستطيع اي
يستطيع اي فريق من استلام هذه الشاحنات
وايصالها الى المنكوبين ان شاء الله فقط
سلامه الموكب مع يعني الشاحنات
وسائدها ولم تكن لديهم اي شروط اخرى هنا
ايضا جمعه يعني هناك تصريحات كرديه اعلنت
بانها تقوم يعني
بنوع من الوساطه مع المتحده مع الاطراف
الدوليه للحديث مع الفصائل وايجاد طريق
امن لمرور هذه الشاحنات هل من اي تطور او
خارق على هذا المستوى
يعني حتى الان لا توجد اي يعني خروفات في
مساله تسجيل العقوبات في دخول هذه
المساعدات كانت نعم الاداره طلبت يعني
القوه الفاعله على الارض وخاصه الولايات
المتحده وروسيا بالتوسط وايضا طلبه الامم
المتحده بالتوسط وادخال هذه المساعدات
اليوم كنا يعني شاهدنا بان هناك لقاء بين
ممثل من المعارضه والاداره في المعبر نفسه
ولكن بعد يعني
الاستماع اليه عاد الى الى منطقه الراعي
وبعد ثلاث ساعات ابلغ المسؤول الكردي هنا
بان المساعدات لم يتم استلامها بمعنى ان
هناك طرف ثالث يضغط على على
المعارضه لمنع استلام والاكيد هو الطرف
تركيا
بحسب مقاله لهذا الموضوع كيف ترد اوساط
قصد على هذا الموضوع
على ارض الواقع يعني الكل يقول بانه سيدخل
وسيسمح للمساعدات بالدخول وسيفتح المعابر
لكن الحقيقه كل المعابر الداخليه في سوريا
مغلفه يعني المعابر بين النظام والمعارضه
مغلقه بين المعارضه والاكراد مغلقه ولم
يتم السماح بدخول اي نوع من المساعدات في
وقت يطالب فيه السوريين المنكوبين شمال
غرب البلاد بكل وشتى انواع المساعدات
والغريب حقا في الامر ان ان السوريين
يحتاجون الى مساعدات ويطلبونها من الخارج
فيما بلادهم غنيه ويستطيعون يعني مساعده
بعضهم يمنعون المساعدات فيما بينهم هذا
واقع غريب على في على الارض يعني لماذا
تفتح المعابر الخارجيه بينما المعابر
الداخليه لا تفتح
وبالتالي ليس فقط تقسيم سياسي وانما تقسيم
انسانه ايضا شكرا لك مراسل العربيه جماع
عكاش حدثتنا من منبج
ابنيه قائمه لكن الى متى دمر الزلزال
سوريا وتركيا الاف الابنيه واستوت بالارض
لكن القائم منها ايضا تصدع وبات ايلا
للسقوط في اي لحظه
لم يتشرد فقط من فقدوا منازلهم بل ايضا
اولئك الخائفون من العوده الى ابنيه
انتشرت في دعاماتها الشروخ وتتمايل من اي
هزه ارتداديه
من سكان مدينه انطاكيا والتي تضررت بشكل
كبير من الزلزال لجات مع زوجها واطفالها
الى مبنى في حديقه ورغم ان منزلها لم يسقط
الا انها تريد المغادره والاستقرار في
مكان امن
نريد المغادره فقدت اربعه من افراد عائلتي
نجا ثلاثه اشقاء فقط نحن عالقونا هنا ولا
يوجد احد لا اعرف كيف سنغادر
رعب وحزن لم يقتصر على من فقدوا احبتهم
ومسكنهم بل حاله عامه سكنت قلوبك كل من
شهد الكارثه التي هزت المنطقه على نطاق
واسع ديسمبر
اعتقدنا في البدايه انه تم تدمير ثلاث او
خمسه مباني فقط وعندما اشرقت الشمس ادركنا
حجم الزلزال وعندها فقط فهمنا الموقف
خياراني لا ثالث لهما امام السكان المناطق
المنكوبه اما المغادره بحثا عن مامن من
الخطر المستمر منذ اسبوع او البقاء بين
الانقاض بانتظار منازل لن تعود على الاقل
في المدى القريب
وكلاهما فيه تشرد ينتظر المنكوبين حتى
اشعار اخر
اذا عمر العربيه
معنى مشاهدينا عضو مجلس اداره الدفاع
المدني احمد يازجي استاذ احمد قبل ان اسال
عن حال المباني عن اخر احصائيات
الجرحى ويعني المفقودين وغيرهم هناك عامل
اساسي اليوم هو المعامل النفسي لكل
المنكوبين بعد هذا الزلزال وطبعا العامل
النفسي يؤثر على عمليه الصمود ما بعد
الخروج من الزلزال كيف يتعاطون مع كل
اليوم الذي يعانون من تروما حقيقيه بعد
هذا الزلزال
العامل النفسي يتعلق في فرق الانقاذ الذي
كانت تعمل الذي تعمل الى حد هذه اللحظه
بالاضافه للمدنيين ايضا فهنالك للعاملين
اثر هذا نفسيا عند خروج كان بعض الحالات
على قيد الحياه كان هناك طرحه عارمه لدى
جميع
متطوعي الخواز البيضاء عند خروج هذه
الحالات الان وبعد
فقدان الامل وخروج احياء يعمل العامل
النفسي اثر على الفرق بالاضافه للعامل
النفسي على المدني ايضا متضررين من الجراء
هذا الزلزال يوجد حاله احباط شديده لجميع
المدنيين المتواجدين الان في سمالوط سوريا
من على الامم المتحده وعمليه تاخير وصول
المساعدات الى شمال
استاذ يعني عاده الامم المتحده
المنظمات
الرسميه والدوليه تساعد كثيرا بهذا العامل
تحديدا هل بداتم ترصدون على الارض اي
مساعده خصوصا ان يعني اليوم ليس فقط موضوع
طعام وماكل ومشرب انما هناك
المساعده انسانيه على المستوى النفسي يجب
ان تتم او اعطائها لكل النجيل من هذا
الزلزال
هنالك بعض الدعم الشعبي والاهل الواصل على
منطقه الشمال سوريا بالاضافه لتقديم بعض
المساعدات من دوله
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وايضا قطر
والعراق وايضا شركائنا في الولايات
المتحده وكندا وبريطانيا
وبعض الدول من الاتحاد الاوروبي يا تاتي
هذه المساعدات متواتره هي لا تلبي الحد
الادنى من المتطلبات ان كان على مستوى فرق
البحث والمقاز العامل العام الذي تعمل على
عمليه الانتشار وايضا بدا مرحله التعافي
من فتح الطرقات الرئيسيه بالاضافه الى
ازاله بعض التصبعات العاصمه
بالاضافه ان هناك بانكم اليوم بحاجه
لمساعدات على المستويين مستوى الايواء
الجسدي ومستوى الاواء النفسي لان يعني
الحالتين متضررتين الكبير استاذ احمد اذا
سالت عن المباني اليوم المتضرره خصوصا
اننا لا نتحدث فقط عن المباني التي سقطت
وانما عن تصدع معظم المباني وبالتالي عن
الملايين الذين سيكونون خارج في العراء
يباتون في الخيام او ربما في الشارع هل
لديك اي احصائيات حول هذا الموضوع وكيف
يمكن ان تنقل الواقع
رصدنا حاليا نحن
هنالك اكثر من 500
قدم بشكل كلي بالاضافه الى اكثر من 300
مبنى قدم بشكل جزئي
كما كان هناك الاف المباني التي قدمت يوجد
عدد كبير من المباني الان هي خطر على
المدنيين يعمل فرق فريق هندسه على
العمل على تقشير هذه المباني بوضع اشارات
تحذيريه بالاضافه الى مدى الخطر الذي يحدث
في هذا المبنى فيوجد ايضا فريق دفاع مدني
مرافق لهذا الفريق الهندسي يضع اشارات
تحذيريه على المباني العمل سوف يستمر
لايام لتحديد المباني الايه الى السقوط
والمباني الخطره بالاضافه الى المباني
المتصدعه ولكن يوجد الان حاله هلع وخوف من
المدنيين الان من العوده الى منازل بسبب
الحاله التي عاشوها جراء هذا الزلزال
فيوجد ايضا حاله
المدنيين الذين تضرروا من هذا الزلزال
وهدمت مبانيهم بالاضافه الى
المدنيين الذين لم يتضررون فيوجد اعداد
كبيره وسطنا تقريبا على الاحصائيه يوجد
اربعين الف عائله الان هيا بلا ماوى
بالاضافه الى 11 الف اصابه تحتاج الى
تمريض والى
وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن يعني عن مساعدات
عاجله لاعاده اعمار عن مساعدات على مستوى
الطبابه استاذ احمد يعني قبل الازمه كنا
نسمع ونقرا التقارير الامميه التي تحدث عن
ان اكثر من اربعه ملايين في المنطقه هناك
يعيشون على المساعدات وعلى الاعاله
الدوليه اليوم مع هذه الكارثه هل لديكم
عدد تقريبي او رقم تقريبي
كما اسلفت يوجد هنالك 40 الف عائله بلا
ماوى بالنسبه للاعانات التي كانت تقدم الا
شمال الارض سوريا قبل حدوث الزلزال ايضا
كانت تاخرت بسبب اليد ادخال المساعدات
بالنسبه لقرار مجلس الامم المتحده فكانوا
هناك ايضا تاخر في اطفاء المساعدات
بالاضافه ان هنالك بعض الدول الالمانحه قد
اوقفت بعض من المشاكل والمستوصفات ايضا
على مستوى حتى الادويه التي كانت تقدم
للقطاع الصحي ايضا كانت متوقفه فالان بعد
حظوظ حدوث الزلزال مما طاقه مع هذه الازمه
وفاطمه الوضع الانساني المتردي الان ونحن
نتكلم الان ودرجه الحراره دون صفراء حاله
ماساويه الان يعيش المدنيون
تتطلب سرعه كبيره باطفاء المساعدات
ومساعدات بحجم اكبر
يكون ذلك
نعم شكرا لك عضو مجلس اداره الدفاع المدني
احمد ياسجي
من جنديرس الصحافه محمد الاشقر ينضم الينا
ايضا لنقل الواقع السوري محمد يعني اليوم
كيف يمكن نقل الصوره هناك في اليوم السابع
على الزلزال خصوصا انك كنت توافين منذ
الايام الاولى عن الصوره الماساويه عن
الحاله الصعب
للعائلات السوريه التي اصبحت معظمها مشرده
هناك
نعم يعني تتواصل المعاناه والماساه هنا في
مدينه جنديرس في ريف حلب بعد مرور سبعه
ايام على بدء هذه الكارثه ان تحدثنا عن
العمليات الميدانيه لانتشال الضحايا من
تحت الانقاض فانها تتواصل في بعض المناطق
التي يتم وصول ابلاغات عن وجود ضحايا تحت
الانقاض فيها الفرق لا تزال منتشره في
جميع الاحياء المدمره في المدينه
بالكامل يعني ايضا يعني هناك يعني خلايا
نحل في الحقيقه تعمل في مدينه جنديرس من
جميع الفرق
التطوعيه الشبابيه والفرق الاهليه التي
شكلت حديثا بعد حدوث هذه الكارثه وايضا
المنظمات
الانسانيه يعني اوضاع ماساويه ان سمحتي لي
ان اسلط الضوء قليلا على ان جين من هذا
الزلزال يعني اوضاع ماساويه يعيشونها
خصوصا في مراكز الايواء المؤقته التي
انشات لهم ايضا في المخيمات التي اقيمت في
محيط مدينه جنديرس يعني كنا قبل قليل في
احد المخيمات يعني
شاهدنا وراينا المعاناه بام اعيننا
نعم اليوم الناجين بحاله صدمه صحيه وصدمه
نفسيه هل يمكن يعني نقل معاناه الاطفال
خصوصا لان يعني هقول الصدمه يكون اعلى
واكبر بكثير
نعم يعني التقينا احد الناجين في المخيمات
يعني احد اطفاله من الرعب لحظه حدوث
الزلزال اصابه مرض السكر هناك كعده اطفال
ناجين قد اصيبوا بحالات مرضيه نتيجه
الصدمه النفسيه التي اصيب بها نتيجه هذا
الزلزال ولكن يعني
هناك الكثير من الاطفال الذين يعانون الان
نحن الان في منطقه شديده البروده درجات
الحراره تحت الصفر يعني
المخيمات التي انشئت في محيط المدينه الى
حد هذه اللحظه لم تصلها الكهرباء يعني طيب
محمد محمد هل هل يتلقى يعني الناجون
العنايه الطبيه
المطلوبه خصوصا وانهم يعني حتى لو لم تكن
الجروح كبيره ولكن هم بحاجه الى عنايه
طبيه الى الى ظروف طبيعيه لكي يعني
يتمكنوا من المعافاه
نعم يعني في الحقيقه بعد الدمار الذي اصاب
مشفى جنديرس نتيجه هذا الزلزال هناك بعض
الفرق التطوعيه المؤلفه من بعض الممرضين
التي تتجول بين الاهالي لاجراء الاسعافات
الاوليه
للمرضى والكبار السن والاطفال الذين
اصيبوا بامراض نتيجه انخفاض درجات الحراره
طبعا بعد تواصلنا مع احدى المنظمات
الشريكه لمركز الملك سلمان الذي ادخل الذي
وصلت مساعداته يوم امس عبر معبر حمام
قالوا انهم يقومون بتجهيز عيادات متنقله
هذه العيادات ستتنقل بين
المتضررين نتيجه هذا الزلزال ويبدو انها
ستبدا عملها خلال الساعات القادمه بعد
دخول قافله المساعدات السعوديه
من مركز الملك سلمان يوم امس عبر معبر
حمام القريب من هذه
المنطقه مدينه جنديرس طبعا مدينه جنديرس
نالت النصيب الاكبر من الدمار والضحايا
عندما نتحدث محمد
عن كل هذا الدمار الذي حل بالمنطقه هل تم
تمشيط كل احياء المنطقه
العدد النهائي للضحايا العدد النهائي
للمفقودين هل هناك اي اعداد تقريبيه وعن
كم عائله نتحدث اليوم هي بحكم المشرده بعد
انهيار المباني هناك
نعم يعني في الحقيقه في مدينه جنديرس لا
توجد احصائيه نهائيه حول اعداد
او المصابين او العائلات المشرده ولكن
يعني بحسب المنقذين الذين عملوا على على
الانقاذ فان اعداد القتله قد فاقت 600
قتيل واعداد المصابين الى حد هذه اللحظه
لا توجد احصائيه حولهم
يمكننا القول بانهم بالالاف في محيط
المدينه والقرى والبلدات الاكثر امنا الذي
التي لم يطلها هذا النصيب من الدمار طبعا
ان سمحت لي ان اتحدث هنا عن سبب غياب
الاحصائيه في هذه المدينه نتيجه الحمله
الاهليه لانتشال الضحايا نتيجه
العدد المباني الكبير الذي تدمر في هذه
المدينه اضطر الاهالي لتشكيل فرق انقاذ
ومساعده فرق الدفاع المدني في انتشال
الضحايا يعني اكثر من جهه عملت على انتشال
الضحايا والانقاذ منذ ساعات الزلزال
الاولى الذي ضرب المنطقه يوم الاثنين
الماضي جميع هذه العوامل تسببت بتاخر
بتاخر اصدار احصائيه رسميه حول اعداد
الناجين او حول اعداد القتلى او المصابين
نتيجه هذا الزلزال شكرا لك بنجنديرس
الصحافه محمد الاشقر على هذه الرساله
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا لنقل الصوره من على الارض وجهود
الانقاذ سينضم الي مراسلي العربيه من ادي
يامان محمود شكر موفد العربيه من هاتاي
جنوب تركيا موفد العربيه عمار الهندي ومن
غازي عنتاب موفد العربيه عبد المحسن
الحربي عبد المحسن سابدا معك بغازي عنتاب
هل يمكن القول الامل ما زال موجود
بانتشال واغاثه المزيد من الناجين بعدما
يعني تقريبا اليوم السابع بعد الزلزال
شارف على الانتهاء
في الحقيقه الجميع هنا من الفرق الانقاذيه
ومن الاهالي ومن جميع متواجدين حتى
المتطوعين الذين يوزعون الاكل والماء
والغذاء بكل بشكل عام متمسكون ببصيص الامل
موجود بالرغم من انه
انقضى سبعه ايام نحن نتجه الى الساعات
الاخيره من اليوم السابع في التالي سندخل
في اليوم الثامن هذه
الامال البسيطه عززتها لحظات الصمت
المتعدده التي تم فرضها قبل قليل من فرق
الانقاذ العامله في هذا المنطق في هذه
المنطقه في غازي عنتاب حيث قبل قليل تم
فرض لحظه صمت استمرت الى نصف ساعه وفي
لحظه الصمت هذه كانت لحظات ترقب كبيره
ربما لمحاوله سماع اصوات او حتى
محاوله للوصول الى حتى الجثث في هذه
المواقع وانتشالها بشكل كامل لاستعدادا
للانتقال الى موقع اخر كما تشاهدين في
الصوره
لقطات كلوز على الفريق الذي حدد الموقع
الذي تم الاستماع فيه ربما الى الصوت حتى
الان لم يتم تحديد ماهيه هذا الصوت بالرغم
من انه عصر هذا اليوم كنا متواجدين هنا تم
تحديد او سماع صوت طفل بشكل مبدئي تم
تحديد هذا المكان تحديدا لان الطفل كان في
هذا الموقع لم يتم التاكيد بشكل كامل فيما
اذا تم
معرفه ماهيته ولكن هم يعملون بالمؤشرات
ولو كانت الضعيفه فرق الانقاذ السعوديه
التي تعمل في هذا الموقع تعمل في
ومعها عدد من الادوات نتحدث عن ادوات
الاستشعار ادوات تقنيه حديثه وحتى ادوات
لاستشعار المناطق الا لسقوط او المباني
الايه للسقوط بالقرب من هذا الموقع
بالتالي يتم حمايه العاملين
الجمهريين من الاهالي بهذه المعدات
بالاضافه لمعدات التي يتم استخدامها للبحث
عن ضحايا او الناجين عمليات الانقاذ مستمر
ليال في هذا الموقع وفي المدينه بشكل عام
تنتشر هذه المواقع بشكل كبير جدا لا تزال
الاعمال جاريه في كل المواقع هنا في غازي
عنتاب ليان عبد المحسن ابقى معي سانتقل
الى
هاتاي جنوب تركيا
والزميل
عمار الهندي عمار يعني بالساعات الاخيره
لاحتماليه يعني نجاه او العثور على ناجين
بالمده الطبيعيه والطبيه لاي انسان ممكن
ان يصمت تحت الانقاذ هل الامال ما زالت
موجوده بهذه المنطقه التي تقريبا يعني
دمرت بشكل كبير
يعني انا اعتقد نعم ان هنالك امل لاننا
نقف على حاله
لشخص ناجن تحت الانقاض فرق الانقاذ الان
يعني تحاول اخراجه وهي بصدد اخراجه كانوا
طلبوا ماء له وبعد ذلك اخذوا حماله
واقتربت من مكان تواجده ما علمناه ان هذه
الجهود وصلت الى ثلاث اشخاص ولكن يعتقد ان
شخصا واحدا فقط من بينهم لا يزال على قيد
الحياه ليال مجرد ان يكون هنالك شخص في
اليوم السابع من هذا الزلزال على قيد
الحياه هذه معجزه حقيقه يعني انا اراقب
هذا المشهد منذ ساعتين تقريبا رجال
الانقاذ هنا كانوا في صدمه اساسا انهم
يعني وجدوا شخصا على قيد الحياه الجميع
هنا كان يعتقد ان الامر قد انتهى وان
نتيجه حتميه وان ليس هنالك اي شخص
سيخرج من هذه المنطقه على قيد الحياه ولكن
بعد ان تاكدوا اول مره ثاني مره وثالث مره
صفقوا ثلاث مرات وكانوا يعني في صدمه
كبيره من وجود ناجين سالت احد رجال
الانقاذ عن الوضع هناك وما الذي يعيق
عملهم قال لي بان هنالك بعض الركام
والحديد البسيط وانهم سيقطعوا هذا الحديد
ويخرجوا هذا الشخص الناجي من تحت الانقاض
كانت قبل لحظات من الان هنالك كان هنالك
صمت طلبوا منا ان نصمت جميعا واستانفوا
العمل سياره الاسعاف حاضره هنا طبعا في
الجهه المقابله من هذا المشهد ليال انا
يعني اود ان انقل لك ماذا ما الذي يحدث
رائحه الموت في المقابل تتواجد في كل مكان
في انطاكيا في هاتاي يعني الجثث تتواجد في
اغلب المواقع التي نمر منها هنالك جثث يتم
اخراجها توضع الى جانب المبنى الذي او
البنايه المنهاره التي استطاع رجال
الانقاذ ان
يعني يخرج منها هذه الجثمين وهؤلاء
الضحايا توضع الى جانب المبنى وبعد ذلك
يطلب ممن يتواجدون من اسرهم الاقتراب
للتعرف عليها من يتعرف على هذه الجثث وهذه
الجثانين
ويثبت انها تخص يعني يصار الى تسليمه هذه
الجثه ويدفنها بمعرفته من لا يستطيع ان
يتعرف احد على جثته تاخذه
السلطات فرق الاسعاف تنقله الى المقبره
الجماعيه مقبره الارقام وهناك في مقبره
الارقام يوضع يتم تصوير الجثه وتوثيقها
ووضع رقم عليها ويدفن هذا الشخص حتى اذا
جاء يوم احد يسال يعود الى قاعده البيانات
والى الصور والى
الارقام ليعرف مكان دفن هذا الشخص الذي
يخص
مكان والعمليات
نحن نتحدث عن مناطق باكمله تحولت الى
ارقام موتى ليس يعني ليس اسماء حتى هي
فعلا كارثه على كافه الصعد والمستويات نعم
عمار ابقى معي لو سمحت ساعود اليك بعد
قليل من ادي يمان مشاهدينا ينضم الي محمود
شكر
لنقل الصوره من هناك محمود يعني هل من
امال ايضا موجوده بهذه المنطقه بوجود
ناجين مع الساعات الاخيره لليوم السابع
في احد الاحياء الداخليه في المدينه
وصادفنا فريقا بريطانيا بالاضافه الى عدد
كبير من الدفاع المدني التركي وكان مع هذا
الفريق كلب مدرب نحن نزلنا لنستطيع المكان
وعلمنا الى ان هذا الكلب هو دخل الى احد
الابنيه
الرصد اذا كان هنالك احياء ولكن ما ان شعر
صاحب البنايه بوجود اعلام حتى هو طلب منا
ان نغادر مما يعني بهذه القصه الى ان
الاعمال لا زالت قائمه حتى الساعه وحتى
هذا التوقيت نحن نتحدث مع ساعه متاخره من
الليل ولكن المفارقه فيها الى ان نقف هنا
في هذه البنايه التي انتهت الاعمال فيها
منذ حوالي نصف ساعه تقريبا هي على مدى
سبعه ايام كان هنالك الضغط على 24 ساعه
للوصول
ان كانوا لاحياء اقرباء لهم هم اشقاء او
اباء كانوا ينتظرون هنا ساذهب بهذه الصوره
للتدليل على الواقع الذي وصلت اليه الامور
كيف ان هؤلاء رجال الدفاع المدني
والمتطوعين انتهوا منذ حوالي ساعه كما قلت
وايضا عثر على الرجل اب ومعه ثلاثه من
اطفاله بالاضافه ايضا الى زوجه ومع الى ام
ومعها طفلتها اذا اخذنا هذه الصوره عند
هذه الحفره التي تظهر ايضا في تلك المنطقه
احد المسعفين قال لي ان
الوجدوا الام
تتابط ابنتها في زاويه الغرفه
بشده وقاموا بجهد لعمليه رفع اليدين عن
جثه الطفله وقال انه للغريب حتى انه ذهب
الى اللغه التركيه قال رائحتها مسك مسك
مسك هي امراه صالحه سالت المترجم انا ماذا
يعني قال هم من سبعه ايام كانوا يتوقعون
ان تخرج جثث لها روائح معينه ولكن الان
كيف ان هذه المراه هذه الام خرجت مع طفلته
كان لو امكن لنا لكنك ايضا دخلنا الى
الزاويه لربما هي بقيت لايام عديده عايشه
حيه تنتظر من ياتي اليها ولكن هنالك صعوبه
لاننا اذا اخذنا ايضا بالصوره الى هذه
البنايه تعلمين مدى البشاعه المشهديه هي
بنايه من ثمانيه طوابق مؤلفه من كل دور
الى اربع شقق الكلام كان يوجد فيها عدد
الضحايا الى خمسين ضحيه سجلت في هذه
البنايه الان انتهت من كل الاعمال ويظهر
انهم ذاهبون الى عمليات رفع الالقاب يعني
محشونه
القول ان اصعب ما في المشاهد التي
شاهدناها بعد هذا الزلزال هي غريزه
الامومه غريزه الانبوبه غريزه الاخوه هذه
الروابط الانسانيه التي شاهدناها حتى بجثث
يعني الموتى ومن قضوا بهذا بالامس كان
هنالك صوره عصفت بها تركيا ثم بعد ذلك
العالم العربي في احد الاحياء بمنطقه اخرى
لرجل لاب هو ادرك ان ابنته قد توفيت ولكن
يدها خارجه من بين الانقاض وهو يضع يده
عليها العجابه في هذه المساله وهي ليست
العجابه او الغرابه هي انه كنا نحن مع
خاصه تغطيات الليليه حتى ساعات الفجر نجد
امهات اباء متقدمين في السن او متقدمات
تربصنا على كرسي لهن لمده عشره او سبع
ساعات ينتظرنا على اساس الامل ولا يريدون
ان يتركنا المكان على قاعده ان ابنائهم او
بناتهم او اشقائهم او اخوانهم لا زالوا
محمود ان يكون هناك مزيد وايضا نعم محمود
ابقى معي ساعود الى الزملاء الى هاتاي
جنوب تركيا ومفرد العربيه عمار الهندي
عمار يعني
بتمشيط المباني
هل تسمعني عمار
بعمليه تمشيط المباني هل يمكن القول بانه
تمشيط كامل المنطقه يعني هل هناك امل
بالعثور على عدد كبير من الناجين ما الرقم
المتوقع للمفقودين او يعني ضحايا هذا
الزلزال بالمنطقه هناك
سابدا من اخر اجيب على اخر سؤال العدد
المتوقع للمفقودين هذا يستحيل الاجابه
عليه حتى تفرغ السلطات من ازاله الانقاض
من جميع البنايات المدمره وبعد ذلك يمكن
ان يعرفوا عدد المفقودين تحت الانقاض
السؤال الذي قبله الذي سبقوا انه هل ازيلت
المناطق كامله وبحث فيها هذا مستحيل هذا
مستحيل لانه هنالك مناطق واسعه جدا حتى
اللحظه يعني بنايات الركام فيها كما هو
وبالتالي هنالك عائلات تنتظر امام هذه
البنايات حتى يصار الى ازاله الانقاض
والكتل الاسمنتيه منها ومعرفه من تحتها من
المفقودين ولكن هنالك ايضا بنايات اخرى يا
ليال منعم مشطت بالكامل هنالك احياء مشطت
بالكامل وتم انتشال كل من فيها من تحتها
من انقاض ود بالفعل
وبالتالي هنالك طبعا احياء ايضا
داخل مدينه انطاكيا لا تزال منكوبه
بالكامل وتحتاج انا اعتقد ان هذه العمليه
ليال لن تنتهي يعني اذا ما اعلنوا مثلا
خلال يومين او غدا او بعد غد بانه لا امل
في العثور عن ناجين وان العمليات الان
تتحول بصدد رفع الانقاض وازاله انتشال
الجثث سيستغرق هذا الامر معهم فتره زمنيه
يعني ليست يوم او يومين يعني هي كميه
الدمار مهوله مهوله مهوله الكاميرا ربما
تنقل مشهد او مقطع او او بنايه واحده ولكن
هل نستطيع ان ننقل كل الدمار الحاصل في
انطاكيا هذا مستحيل وبالتالي اعتقد ان
العمليه تحتاج الى وقت واعتقد ان السؤال
الاهم وان محور الحديث وان الاهتمام
والاعين ستتجه
خلال الايام القادمه الى موضوع الجثث
وموضوع الخوف من الاوبئه والخوف من
الامراض والخوف من ان تبقى جثث على سبيل
المثال اكثر من اسبوعين تحت الجثث على تحت
الانقاض ربما لان هذه العمليه كما قلت لك
ستستغرق وقت واعتقد من خلال ما اراه في
انطاكيا ومن خلال التجوال بين الاحياء
يعني دمار هائل
نعم والامم المتحده بدات بالتحذير من هذا
الموضوع بانه ممكن ان يكون يعني ان يكون
يعني يدق ناقوس الخطر حول الامراض وحول ما
يمكن ان ينتج عنه ولكن طبعا كما ذكرت
الدمار مهول ونتحدث عن مناطق شاسعه وكبيره
وبالتالي ايضا فرص يعني النجاه ما زالت
موجوده وبالتالي لا يمكن انتشال الجميع
على انهم ضحايا اسمح لي عمار ان اعود
للزميل عبد المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن يعني
بهذا الاطار وباختصار هل تمت عمليه تمشيط
كامله اهم ما المتوقع يعني كم من الوقت ان
تاخذ بالايام المقبله
من الواضح ان المنطقه لم يتم تنشيطها بشكل
كامل استند الى ذلك بالحديث عن فرق
الانقاذ التي تقول في هذه المنطقه التي
تقول انها ستنتقل بعد الانتهاء من هذا
الموقع الى مواقع اخرى فبالتالي هنالك بعض
المواقع اما لم يتم الوصول اليها او
سيذهبون لمسانده الفرق الموجوده فيها ويوم
الامس كنا في جوله من
الحدود التركيه السوريه ونحن عائدون
شاهدنا عشرات المواقع في عدد من القرى في
جنوب تركيا وتحديدا بالقرب من الحدود
السوريه بعدد مواقع مهدمه بهذه الطريقه
والمباني لا يوجد لديها احد كما وصلتني
ايضا عدد من الرسائل من اشخاص من مختلف
المناطق تحديدا من انطاكيا يقولون بانهم
لديهم ثلاثه ابناء او من ذويهم من اسرتهم
ويصورون المنطقه التي وقعت ويقولون بان
احد لم منذ وقوع الزلزال الحاجه كبيره جدا
لفرق الانقاذ لا زالت بالرغم من مرور
ثمانيه ايام وحتى مع مرور تسعه ايام وعشره
ايام الحاجه ستكون اكبر ليست فقط لانتشال
ناجين وهي معجزه ان حدثت ولكن انتشال
الجثث ولرغبه اهاليهم باستلام هذه
الجثث من هذه المواقع المهدمه ايضا
للانتقال الى المرحله الاخرى وهي مرحله
اعاده الاعمار ومرحله ما بعد هذه الكارثه
بالاضافه الى التركيز على ربما قضايا اخرى
بعد عمليات الانقاذ نتحدث عن عشرات الاسر
الذين هم خارج منازلهم بسبب
الخطوره الكبيره جراء هذا الزلزال تحدث عن
هنا فقط في غازي عنتاب اكثر من 2500 منزل
ايل للسقوط بالتالي الاف الاسر تحدث عن
20% من سكان غازي عنتاب خرجوا من منازلهم
والكثير منهم غادر المدينه وايضا هنالك
يتواجد الكثير منهم في مناطق
مختلفه في المدينه هم متواجدون في الحدائق
متواجدون في الاماكن العامه ينمون
بالسيارات ان وجدت شكرا لكم مراسله
للعربيه بنغازي عنتاب عبد المحسن الحربي
من هاتاي جنوب تركيا عمار الهندي ومن اذيه
محمود شكر شكرا لكم مراسلي العربيه على
هذه الرسائل
[موسيقى]
غير قوه الزلزال الهائله ثم عوامل اخرى
كان لها دور في ارتفاع اعداد الضحايا
فزلزال وحده لا يقتل الناس انما ايضا
مخالفات البناء فلنتابع
شواهد قبور ضحايا الزلزال باتت تميز
بالارقام بدلا من الاسماء
فالتعرف على هويه الضحايا لم يعد متاحا
لذويهم امام حجم الكارثه
[موسيقى]
قوه زلزال عند سبع درجات لم تسجل في
التاريخ الا 20 مره كان اخرها في نيبال
بقوه سبع درجات فاصل ثمانيه عام 2015
حينها اودى بتسعه الاف شخص
هناك عوامل اخرى غير حركه الطبقات
التكتونيه كانت وراء وقوع هذه الاعداد
الضخمه
[موسيقى]
مباغته الزلزال في الرابعه صباحا جعلت
النائمون يجدون انفسهم عانقين عندما
انهارت منازلهم فضلا عن تاخر استجابه اطقم
الاغاثه في هذه الساعه المبكره
عشر ولايات ضربها الزلزال شتت جهود عمليات
الانقاذ من حيث تحديد اولويه المناطق
الاكثر احتياجا
فالساعات الذهبيه هي الاولى في عمليات
الانقاذ لكنها جاءت متاخره بفعل انهيارات
الطرق المؤديه الى المواقع المتاثره ليصل
بعضهم في اليوم الثاني والثالث الى تلك
الوجات
مخالفه متعهد البناء لمعايير مقاومه
الزلزال التي تفردها التشريعات في تركيا
على وضع زلزال عام 1999
سيدي الحديدي العربيه
مشاهدينا مجددا الى جنديرس والصحافه محمد
الاشقر محمد سابدا من تصريح الاتحاد
الاوروبي الذي يقول بانه يجب دخول مساعدات
الان الى شمال غرب سوريا من خلال ثلاثه
معابر حدوديه ما هي المعابر اليوم القابله
لان تستخدم لايصال المساعدات الى شمال
السوري
نعم يعني في الحقيقه المعابر المهيئه
والجاهزه لدخول المساعدات الدوليه من عبر
تركيا هي معبر باب الهوى في ريف ادلب
ومعابر حمام وباب السلامه ومعبر الراعي
ومعبر جرابلس في ريف حلب اقربها الى
المناطق المتضرره في ريف ادلب هو معبر باب
الهوى المعترف فيه من قبل الامم المتحده
لدخول المساعدات الامميه
والاقرب الى الى الى المناطق المتضرره في
ريفا حلب مثل مدينه جنديرس هناك معبر حمام
الذي يبعد عن هذه المدينه بضع الكيلو
مترات وايضا معبر باب السلامه يعتبر قريب
ايضا على المناطق المتضرره هنا في مدينه
جنديرس ومحيطها اما بالنسبه لمعبر جرابلس
فهو الابعد عن هذه المنطقه ومعبر باب
السلامه ايضا
معبر الراعي عفوا يعتبر بع نوعا ما عن هذه
المناطق المتضرره طبعا جميع المعابر من
الطرف السوري
مجهزه وجاهزه لاستقبال المساعدات طبعا
بالنسبه للطرقات من الطرقات من الجانب
التركي طبعا دخلت المساعدات من معبر باب
الهوى رغم الاضرار التي اصابت الطرقات
ايضا دخلت مساعدات من قبل معبر حمام
رغم الاضرار التي اصابت المنطقه خصوصا ان
معبر حمام قريب من المناطق التي
ضربها الزلزال في ولايه هاتاي اما معبر
باب السلامه فهو يعني يطل على مدينه كلس
التركيه ايضا هذه المدينه التي اصابها
الزلزال اما بالنسبه لمعبر الراعي فهو
قريب من مدينه غازي عنتاب ايضا احدى المدن
والبلدات التي
اصابها وتضررت نتيجه الزلزال الذي ضرب
سوريا وتركيا الى حد هذه اللحظه يعني ان
تحدثنا عن المساعدات الامميه التي دخلت
الى سوريا هناك 52 شاحنه امميه دخلت عن
طريق معبر باب الهوى كان اولها يوم الخميس
الماضي عندما دخلت سته شاحنات يعني واخرها
كان اليوم عندما دخلت عشره شاحنات جميع
هذه الشاحنات الاثنان وخمسين هي مساعدات
امميه مخصصه لمتضرري الزلازل باستثناء
الست شاحنات التي دخلت في اول يوم وهو يوم
الخميس عندما قال ناشطون اغاثيون ان هذه
الشاحنات كانت مجدوله
لاحدى المنظمات الانسانيه عن طريق
المساعدات الدوريه التي تدخل قبل ان اختم
قبل سوريا الاتحاد الاوروبي ايضا يقول بان
مستشفيات شمال غرب سوريا وهناك حاجه
لمعدات ثقيله لازاله الانقراض وطبعا
لمساعدات طبيه هل هناك اي جدوله لمساعدات
طبيه من قبل الصحه العالميه باختصار
نعم يعني ان تحدثنا عن الحاجه الحاجه
الشمال شمال غرب سوريا للمساعدات الطبيه
فنحن نتحدث عن منطقه تعاني الحرب من 12
عاما اي انها تعاني من نقص في التجهيزات
الطبيه والادويه والمستهلكات الطبيه بشكل
عام يعني
اما بالنسبه للاجهزه والمعدات الثقيله
لازاله الانقاض وانتشال ما تبقى من ضحايا
تحت الانقاض فمنذ الدقائق الزلزال الاولى
او ساعات الزلزال الاولى والناشطون
والدفاع المدني والجميع يطلق نداءات
استغاثه الى للخارج لارسال هذه المعدات
الضروريه جدا في شمال غرب سوريا
متاخر ولكن خير ان ان يتم استخدام من ان
لا يتم شكرا لك من جنديرس الصحافي محمد
الاشقر على هذه الرساله
سقط احد عمال الانقاذ في هذا الموقع
وحصلت له اصابه في يده وايضا طلبوا طواقم
الاسعاف التي حضرت وكانت موجوده هنا اصلا
قاموا باسعافه بشكل او بلف ضماد وضع ضماد
في يده ومن ثم نقله الى مشفى قريب من
نوردا سيتم علاجه هناك ثم استكمل العمل
حيث توقف العمل لمده تقريبا عشر دقائق
لحين اسعافي ومن ثم استثمر العمل
[موسيقى]
خلاص انا معك
الوضع هنا صعب للغايه امي واختي ما زالتا
تحت الانقاض ولا استطيع الوصول اليهما باي
شكل من الاشكال انهما تموتان تحت الانقاض
وانا اموت هنا
[موسيقى]
لقد تلاشت امال الان امل فقط ان يخرجوا من
هنا لا احد يساعد لا اتوقع اي شيء من
الحكومه بعد الان
[موسيقى]
وشاهدينا مع هذه الصوره الماساويه محل
العديد من العائلات هناك نكمل هذه التغطيه
المباشره والان الى الزميل طاهر بركه
[موسيقى]